Sky correspondent to of course met
shamima begum Ali is this a surprise
this ruling
yeah I think it is well certainly the
security sources that I spoke to ahead
of the ruling did feel that probably she
would be having her British nationality
British citizenship restored because uh
what their feeling was that perhaps it
was legally untenable to keep it revoked
so I think in that respect it is a
surprise when I interviewed her I did
ask her about this eventuality and what
would happen if she didn't have her
passport returned to her and her
nationality given back and she said
there is no plan B the British
government argument would be that the
plan for her is to pursue the route
through Bangladesh her father has some
Bangladesh Heritage and that is why the
British government argued that they are
in a position to revoke her British
nationality shamima begum's counter
argument is that she's never been to
Bangladesh at all she has no links with
Bangladesh and if she went back there
then she could possibly face the death
penalty
um I haven't spoken to any of our
contacts in the Kurdish authorities who
control that part of Northeast Syria yet
what I would say is that the Kurds more
generally feel that the situation as it
is at the moment that is that there are
hundreds of men women and children with
links to Islamic State in prison camps
in Northeast Syria well they think that
is untenable because they simply don't
have the resources or the ability to
keep these camps secure or put any of
these individuals on trial themselves
and so they want uh Western nations in
particular to bring their citizens back
to their respective countries and put
them on trial so
I suspect that this decision won't be
entirely popular amongst Kurdish
authorities but we will chat to some and
get their reaction but I think probably
it is a surprise yes but and it is hard
to see where shimima begum does go from
here you know she has gone down a couple
of legal routes now uh has been
unsuccessful at every turn and so I'm
not sure what her uh her ability to
appeal it is from from this moment